that ended annoying to go series
production hybrids have been on the
market since the late 1990s as car
dentistry Manuel Schaefer most of them
have a futuristic appearance and low
drag that goes for the Toyota Prius the
granddaddy of all hybrid vehicles and
the current hyundai ioniq
but the kia Niro which has the same
technology as the ionic looks like a
normal crossover SUV kaabah and guns
under inve tanea see time to house me
and guns no modest crossover SUV
so at first glance you might not believe
that this Korean model has hybrid drive
it has a system capacity of 104
kilowatts and makes do with a very
modest 4.4 liters per 100 kilometers in
combined fuel consumption we're testing
the variant with the top trim line the
spirit whose price starts in just over
30000 euros in Germany but the basic
version Edition 7 offers enough creature
comforts to like dual zone climate
control for example
[Music]
he hid down here behind the air-intake
the kia Niro has adjustable slats at
high speeds they fold shut creating an
air cushion in front of them and that
makes the air outside move past the car
lowering wind resistance Mita Stanfill
ingot the Nero's exterior looks quite
modern the xenon headlights only come
with the top trim level the same goes
for the front parking sensors the spirit
variant also features 18 inch alloy rims
and tinted rear windows
[Music]
the Nero is around four point four
meters long and has a wheelbase of two
point seven meters chrome trim gives the
car and air of luxury conspicuous in the
rear are the big taillights they and a
large bumper make the car seem very
broad
[Music]
under the hood is a 1.6 liter gasoline
engine and a 32 kilowatt electric motor
the key annuity the Kia Niro has all
kinds of technical gadgets he manual
especially likes the inductive charging
station in the center console if you
have a compatible smartphone you just
set it down here and it charges and you
don't have to fool around with cables
and sockets the trunk offers 427 liters
of storage space fold the back seat down
and you've got 1425 liters the interior
makes a good impression - and the neros
basic version 150 euros extra will get
you a leather steering wheel the JBL
sound system with 320 watts and 7
speakers delivers very good sound and is
included in the spirit line that leather
seats will set you back an additional
1,500 euros backseat passengers have
enough legroom
a hybrid engine is very useful
especially in stop-and-go traffic the
electric motor gets you started from a
stop kia says you can run solely on the
electric engine up to 120 kilometers an
hour provided you don't stomp on the go
pedal too much unlike a plug-in hybrid
the neros battery is charged by a
regenerative braking system the
six-speed dual-clutch transmission is
efficient and makes driving a pleasure
[Music]
Nakia new IKEA Nero one Amana while over
entirely he says those wanting to check
out the competition in the crossover
hybrid segment could try the Toyota CHR
but its entry-level price is over 2500
euros higher the Niro slowed top speed
of 162 kilometers an hour makes it a
good car for Sunday drives in the
country and everyday driving in the city
here the Korean hybrid really comes into
its own
[Music]
you